[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That was awesome.
Hi, and welcome to "I/O Life.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and I'm
standing here with Magnus.
Magnus, how are you doing?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hi.
I'm fine, Timothy.
How are you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
I am really good.
We're in the ML booth.
It's my favorite booth.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yep.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Don't tell
the other booths that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Of course not.
It's exciting in here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
in this sandbox,
we are looking at-- right
now, we're in a track,
and there's cars going around.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Exactly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
What's happening here?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: This is
a self-driving car track.
These are actually
something called Donkey Car.
We'll post the link
later on to these things.
You can build them yourself.
There are full instructions
on the internet.
It's built on Raspberry Pi.
And we put a TensorFlow
Lite model on there,
running [INAUDIBLE].
And then we trained
them around this track.
And they're capable of
going around like this.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
It's amazing.
So Raspberry Pi was just
a supported platform
by TensorFlow Lite.
So it really opens up
a lot of possibilities
to do these kinds of things.
So it's really, really exciting.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, and
this is just so delightful.
I saw them training it earlier
where it's just a phone on it.
And he was operating
it with another phone.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And then
the autonomous vehicle
used a model built on
those driving instructions.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Exactly.
So it takes images when
it's going around the track,
and then it's using those
images to train the car,
so it knows where to
go and also how fast
to go in each of the
segments of the track.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
What else do we got
going on in this sandbox?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So as we
heard from the keynote,
we just launched a new
version of the TPU, TPU v3.0.
Should we check that out?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Cool!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Over there?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's do it.
Wait a second.
I think I see Zak
Stone over there.
Is that Zak?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Do you think
we could get him over here?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Zak, come over.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
this is TPU v3.0.
ZAK STONE: That's right.
This is our latest
and greatest TPU.
Actually, this is just
a part of the TPU pod
that contains many
boards like this.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How-- how many?
ZAK STONE: Enough to deliver
more than 100 petaflops
of computers.
That's kind of hard
to think about--
100 petaflops.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How do you
conceptualize 100 petaflops?
ZAK STONE: So it's not
quite apples to apples,
but some of the top
supercomputers in the world
are only doing a few
more than 100 petaflops.
And so we use reduced
precision that's
appropriate for
machine learning.
So like I said, this is
not a direct comparison,
but there are very few
computers in the world that
can do more than that many
mathematical operations
per second.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
And we were talking
to Jeff yesterday.
He mentioned that this is
the first liquid cooled
component in our data centers.
ZAK STONE: That's right.
To the best of my
knowledge, this
is the largest-scale
liquid cooling system
that we've deployed
here at Google.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's exciting.
And it's really pretty.
ZAK STONE: I'd love to have
one of these in my living room,
on my wall, all over
my house, actually.
That would be great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
a little bit more
background on what people
are doing or will be doing
with something like this soon.
ZAK STONE: Sure.
Well, so today, if you look over
here, that second generation
system, that's a cloud TPU.
Anybody with a GCP
project, there's
no more requesting
quota, waiting in line.
Anybody today can
start up a cloud TPU
and use one of our open
source reference models
for image recognition,
for speech recognition,
for machine translation,
language modeling,
even generating images from
scratch, pixel by pixel.
And it all runs on this amazing,
self-contained supercomputer
here.
That's 180 teraflops over there.
And so that's pretty exciting.
We're trying to make
machine learning
acceleration affordable and
accessible to everybody.
And then we are just
relentless about pushing
the envelope of performance
with these new generations
of hardware, like
you're seeing here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome, Zak.
Thank you, so much.
ZAK STONE: Any time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
Magnus, what's next?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK, cool.
Let's go over and check
out an object detection
robot at the TF Lite stand.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I love robots.
Let's do it.
SPEAKER 2: So basically here
we have a TensorFlow Lite model
running on a Raspberry Pi.
This is a very cheap and
easy to find computer.
And what we've done
with it is we've
added a servo motor,
or two servo motors,
that can actually point the
camera in different directions.
So the TensorFlow Lite
model detects objects,
and then it tries to
center them on the screen.
So it's like a
virtual camera person
that's able to keep things
in frame as they move.
So if you take the
apple or the banana
and you put it in the
frame, it will start
to actually move the camera.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So
what this thing is doing
is that it's presenting
us with words.
And then it knows
related words by having
been trained on the huge data
set that puts those words close
together.
And then we use our brains
to do the association.
And if the answers are
matching each other,
then I'm successful.
Otherwise, I'm not.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And this
seems like just fun.
But what's represented there
is a dramatic reduction
in the work to build
something like this,
because the associations
are created by a model
rather than a whole bunch of
people working all those rules
together.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
And, yeah, exactly.
And these models, they
actually exist pre-built.
So you can actually reuse
one in your own app.
You should definitely
check out a technology
called TensorFlow
Hub on tensorflow.org
where we have these types
of models available.
The classical example
for this relationship
is if you take Paris,
and then you add France,
and then you subtract
Italy, what do you get?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Something else?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
You get Rome, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Sure.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Exactly.
And that's how we
calculate the distances
between these vectors.
So Paris is related to
France in the same way
that Italy is related to Rome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, OK.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
So I'm playing a game here.
And I need to associate
things with the word
here and bring it down
into the green area here.
So you can see, I wasn't--
so school, what is the
association to school for you?
Pupil?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Homework?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
Pupil is fine.
OK.
Because that's nice.
I took that out.
So what the machine
learning algorithm knows,
it knows about all of
these associations.
So garden is related to hose.
Shoe is related to--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Foot.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Foot?
Yeah.
Good job, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you, Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
The newspaper is--
so what should we do?
"New York Times?"
Yeah.
It's a newspaper, right?
So I bring these words down.
And eventually, it's
going to build up.
So I got to get faster and
faster at these things.
Horse, riding?
Riding.
OK.
So let's see here.
We now have hamster.
Hamster?
Fluffy?
Fluffy!
Fluffy worked!
Yeah!
Motorcycle, fast?
No.
Motorcycle?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Riding.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Ride?
Well, yeah, that's right.
Summer, winter.
Hot?
Well, summer, hot.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks,
for the tour, Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: You're
so welcome, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And if you'd like
to learn more about TensorFlow,
head on over to tensorflow.org.
If you'd like to learn more
about any of our developer
products, sign up
at g.co/dev/form.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]